fear is real but I am going to share a
secret weapon that I have used for years
to beat every single fear that used to
stop me you're going to use my five
second rule in combination with what I
call an anchor thought and that is going
to reframe what your mind is doing so
that your mind goes from feeling
agitation and making you afraid to
reframing it from agitation to
excitement it works like magic now I
have used this technique for years
literally for years and one of the ways
that I want to introduce you to it is I
want to take you backstage I want to
take you backstage to a speech that I
delivered this year and what you're
going to see is you're going to see me
behind the major set I'm about to walk
out you can kind of hear the crowd
roaring my introductory video is playing
my body is in a state of arouse I am
literally my heart is racing my arms are
sweating like you're going to see this
and you're going to watch me use this
same technique I'm going to teach you to
reframe my nerves into excitement check
this out need motivation you better
watch to top 10 We Believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because of my first business I
quit on my business partner I was making
300 bucks a month and I didn't have the
motivation to keep going and the thing
that got me through was studying the
stories of entrepreneurs who've had
massive success and I hope that in
sharing these stories with you you find
a motivation to keep going and if I'm
being honest I still need the source for
myself today too so today let's learn
from one of the best Mel Robbins and my
take on her top 10 rules of success
enjoy
all right I'm about to go on stage there
are 7 000 people out there and it's so
exciting because
what they don't know is they're about to
learn the five second rule and their
lives will never be the same again now
I gotta tell you my heart is racing
um my armpits are sweating
I have the exact same physiological
feeling is when I'm afraid but I'm not
afraid I'm excited excitement and fear
is the exact same thing in your body
it's just what your brain calls it
here's a trick that's proven by science
that I use every time I speak when I
start to sweat when I start to have
butterflies when I start to have my
heart race I say I'm excited I'm excited
to get out there I'm excited to talk to
these people I'm excited to share the
five second rule and what that does is
it sends a message to my brain that
tells my brain why my body's all
agitated and excited and that way I
don't feel afraid remember excitement
and fear exact same thing in your body
the only difference is what your brain
calls
go get them rule number two claim your
wins two wins is a way to practice
gratitude
um and to train yourself
to start to
see what's going right in your life
celebrate and claim the wins
uh that you see in your life and
also claim the wins that you want to
create in the future so here's the way
that Chris and I have been doing it
Chris and I every single day whether
we're taking a walk in the morning or
we're sitting having coffee in the
morning or we do it with our kids at
dinner at night we've done it with
friends it's starting to spread like
wildfire through my company as
everybody's taking it on because it's
really fun and here is the simple way
you do two wins right
uh two ends the way that we've been
doing it is you
I know I'm going on and on and on I'm a
little add right now we just got out of
the house for a three day way we've been
doing
oh the way we've been the first let me
tell you how we've been doing it
we have been telling ourselves and each
other
what's one win in the last 90 days
and what is a win that you've had in the
last 24 hours
and what I love about it as I explained
on this video that we did on Instagram
that went crazy viral and you guys had
all kinds of questions about
it is
um
he had questions about
do you have to say it out loud yes you
do because part of it is not just
thinking it it's starting to express it
and allowing somebody else in your life
to hear it so that they can hold space
for your wins and help you celebrate too
but the peace that we've been missing
Chris
as we've been missing the piece
that is the third part so 90 days last
24 hours you need to claim the win you
want to create
in the next 90 days pretty cool huh
so eyes on the road
yeah and that can change every day and
so that was one of the big questions
when you celebrate your wins you do your
three wins that's what we're calling it
three wins we were calling it two wins
but this is now called the three wins as
you
speak what your wins are past 90 days
past 24 hours you then claim and speak
what you want your win to be and are
going to work for in the next 90 days
I love this I love this claiming your
wins so Chris and I are going to do this
right now so that you can watch How We
Do It three wins yes we are
so
in the last 90 days a big win for me
foreign
[Music]
oh
having a
daughter who is starting her senior year
in college
and who seems so happy
that we have not heard from her
literally in like five days and that's a
huge win because normally I hear from
her every day but when she's happy and
busy we don't hear from her so that's a
big win for me last 24 hours
big win
[Music]
or not even a big list
a small win is that I've gotten into the
car here with Chris and we are heading
[Laughter]
out that's a huge win we are heading out
to celebrate our 26th wedding
anniversary away for three nights
um I will take
um responsibility for the fact that we I
saw the road please I'd like to get
there but you're so beautiful oh that's
a win but my husband just complimented
me
um
no but I am two hours late we thought we
would leave by 1 15. it is 3 15. so it's
a big win that I'm in the car
um and about to have three days of Chris
and now I'm gonna claim a win in the
next 90 days
a win I'm gonna claim in the next 90
days
I feel like this anniversary is a big
anniversary for us
26 years
especially after what has been a really
hard two years
and in the next 90 days the win that I'm
going to claim
is that
we're going to look at each other and go
oh my God we have launched a whole new
chapter in our marriage
and it's the best most exciting
amazing
sexy fabulous one yet
rule number three start doing the small
things and it's this idea that
you don't ever start
you stay trapped in your head and if you
feel paralyzed if you've been spinning
the same ideas over and over and over
again then you know what I'm talking
about you see many of you are thinking
way too big you're attaching way too
much pressure on the things that you're
interested in until you start blogging
about fashion you won't even know if you
like it so thinking that you have a
dream about doing it and thinking that
you have this grand plan that you're
going to do it full time it is a
complete and utter waste of your time to
be dreaming that big and let me tell you
why because oftentimes if you're the
kind of person like Vicki that's getting
trapped up here the bigness of what
you're thinking about is what's stopping
you what I want you to do if you're in
Vicki's situation is I want you to stop
dreaming and I want you to just start
doing small things I want you to go back
to curiosity and less into crushing your
big goals thing about life and business
and success is that you have to be
willing to start and for people that
procrastinate starting is the hardest
part for people that worry for people
that think too big starting is the
hardest part folks that study
procrastination talk about the fact that
the only way to beat procrastination is
to create what they call a starting
ritual which is a way to push yourself
to get started because all the research
shows that if we can push you to get
started on something you'll likely keep
going rule number four eliminate
toxicity you shouldn't feel alone
because so many people have anxiety
about toxic relationships related to
their families and how they have to
confront them during the holidays so
here's the thing I want you to think
about when it comes to the holidays
holidays can be one of two things when
you have toxic relationships with your
family it can either be a personal
challenge or or it can be a chance to
have a personal transformation and the
personal transformation that I'm talking
about is not changing your mother or
your annoying older brother or your
racist Aunt I'm talking about whether or
not you have a personal transformation
because you can't fully get rid of toxic
situations or toxic people but you can
transform how you behave when you're
around those kinds of people so the
holidays can be a chance for you to
practice boundaries practice
self-control to be emotionally resilient
and strong and not get triggered and to
also have the courage to express the new
you to express your true self so if you
left home a long time ago you've grown
as a person you've changed you've
evolved and then every time you go back
home you feel like you've stepped into a
Time Warp and you're suddenly eight
years old again this is a chance to
transform yourself so that when you walk
in the door you are who you are now not
who you used to be when you still lived
at home and so there's a couple things
that I want you to think about before
you go home before you have the
interaction so that you are prepared
emotionally to make this a
transformation for yourself personally
number one don't assume the old role
that you used to play so just because
you're in your childhood home or you're
with people that you know from your
childhood do not make the mistake of
falling back into Old patterns don't
suddenly start acting like the youngest
one again if you're the youngest in your
family if you'd always been dad's
favorite and everybody hates that stop
playing into it so there are things that
we do that we don't even realize when we
step into our childhood homes or around
the people that we grew up with where we
slip right back into Old patterns make
sure you know what those are so that you
have them in check for yourself number
two this is a huge one don't take the
bait this was advice that I got for my
brother a long time ago don't take the
bait you know that there are relatives
and friends from your past that just
love the cast The Guilt they just loved
to cause issues they're constantly
casting like a fisherman all kinds of
things out there and if you're the kind
of person like I used to be when
somebody gets upset you grab the bait
and then you start trying to make it
okay and the next thing you know you're
arguing with somebody over something
really stupid just don't take it don't
let yourself get triggered if somebody's
cast in The Guilt let them cast don't
hit that lure you know what I'm saying
they're welcome to say whatever they
want to say if you don't react there's
no issue you don't have to worry about
making sure that your mom or your dad
doesn't say that stuff just don't react
to it and you'll be shocked at how the
dynamic changes you know this is another
piece of advice that my friend Danielle
gave me today and it comes from the com
app you can also before you go into the
situation visualize it's a really busy
road now in a very busy road there are
people that are passengers in those cars
and there are people that are
pedestrians on the sidewalk who are
watching the cars go by I want you to
think about the dynamic in your family
as cars zipping down the highway right
everybody's got all kinds of issues and
conversations and kids and this and that
and people want attention and there's
all kinds of things racing by your role
when you're around your family is to be
a pedestrian on the sidewalk watching it
all go by this is another form of not
taking the bait the last thing you want
to do when your mom pulls the guilt
train up is to climb on board and be a
passenger on that ride okay you know
what I'm saying you're going to stay on
the sidewalk you're not going to take
the bait you're just going to watch the
traffic as it speeds and whips by don't
climb in when the guilt car pulls up
okay next thing this has also been a
major thing for me empathy empathy is a
superpower my relationship with my mom
changed dramatically for the better when
I stopped judging her and I started
thinking about what she must be feeling
seriously like if you've got somebody in
your life that's angry that says hurtful
things that's
disappointed or upset all of those
things anger pain disappointment it's
all just a mask for Hurt So any kind of
toxic behavior that you're seeing in
other people unless it's some sort of
narcissism personality disorder for most
normal human beings if they're
exhibiting bad behavior it's literally
just unexpressed hurt that's all that it
is and a healthy dose of empathy like
thinking about how hard it was in the
household where your parents grew up or
thinking about all the struggles that
maybe one of your siblings who's really
annoying because they take up all the
energy how many struggles they've faced
or thinking about how lonely your aunt
is because your uncles died thinking
from a point of view that's empathetic
it's amazing it's very personally
transforming because it helps you set
boundaries it helps you not get
triggered it helps you to be more
emotionally mature and resilient and it
will help you make these holidays an
opportunity for personal transformation
instead of a massive of personal
challenge also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five claim your anxiety the
two forms of anxiety
are over functioning and under
functioning
now neither one is better or worse
they're just patterns
and the cool thing with patterns
is once you can spot them and talk about
them
and you understand them and unpack them
you can start to create mindfulness and
a little bit of distance between the
things that trigger your anxiety and
that coping mechanism kicking in
because for me
when I get into the mode of doo doo doo
plan plan plan I got it I got it I got
it
I drive myself into the ground
I burn out
and that's exactly what happened this
weekend
six weeks
of basically going into hyper drive mode
as a way to cope with all this
uncertainty led me to crash
because I'm terrible at asking for help
and my husband
I'll have to ask him how he copes with
his anxiety because he has a really
amazing way of staying calm so over
functioning anxiety
is doo doo doo
it's ah giving advice instead of asking
for help it's assuming responsibility
for things that aren't necessarily your
responsibility it's managing everybody
else's emotions and I am the master at
this
and
the other form of anxiety is
underperforming and as I was thinking
about this
one of my three kids has this form and I
never would have
thought it given their personality
underperforming is when instead of
thinking through your issues you start
asking for tons of advice
you push the responsibility to other
people to solve your issues you
withdrawal you become paralyzed
and
the reason why it's important
to really think about what kind of
anxiety you have and what I want you to
do is in the comments I want you to
write down
are you a over functioning over
performing anxiety person or you are a
under functioning underperforming
and
what happens
when you are over functioning is I Rob
the people around me
of
supporting me of being responsible for
themselves of helping out
I Rob myself of the support that I need
and deserve
and
if you stay in the pattern too long
of either under or over functioning
you will drive yourself into the ground
again you've gotta Express these
emotions
because burying them has never worked in
the history of time
and so what I want you to do is again
write in the comments
what is your pattern
when you feel anxious do you over
function or under function
and the solution
today is very simple
I just want you to recognize the pattern
and for you over functioners
when you recognize yourself going into
that mode
take a pause
get into your body
ask yourself
what do I need help with
and who can I ask for help and what am I
taking on that I don't need to take on
and how could I get myself into this
moment and ground yourself
and if you are an under functioner same
thing
recognize when you're spinning
and asking for advice or overthinking or
paralyzed
instead of
problem solving and getting into action
rule number six is find your life raft
when your life blows up
and you find yourself in the ocean with
like pieces of the boat all around look
for a life preserver or a raft okay so I
want to applaud you for doing what
needed to be done
when the you know what hit the fan
that same instinct is what is going to
make you successful
the second thing that I want to tell you
is once you get a hold of that life raft
you want to grab something else that
floats right and get yourself out of
that water and so I am glad to hear that
you're looking for a job and what I
would recommend is I would recommend not
pretending
about the situation that you're in
there is no shame in going to a job
interview and at the end of it saying
and I'm asking you for this job and the
reason why I'm asking you for this job
is not only because I am going to be
incredible at it and you're never going
to regret it but I actually need it
I'm in a really tight Jam
I had a life crisis happen I never
thought at the age of 55 I'd be in this
situation and I need the work and I want
the work which means I'm going to show
up here every single day
and I am going to work the heck out of
this job
I've never wanted a job more than I want
a job right now
and you should tell your friends that
this is what you're going through and
that you need help and that you need a
recommendation or you need a place to
stay
and you should not do what I did which
was hide what was going on because I was
so ashamed
and you know I'm also going to tell you
it will take time five years ago I still
have the liens on this house
five years ago guys
and so it will take time
for you to climb out of this but you
will climb out of this
when you're in a storm
and when the lights go out in your life
and things feel really dark and really
heavy
there is always been one thing that
helps me get through those moments and
it's reminding myself that this moment
like every painful moment of my life
was temporary it passed
and when you can keep telling yourself
this moment is it's gonna pass and it's
it's it's leading me somewhere when you
can trust in that
you create your own light in that dark
tunnel
and it allows you to look up and one of
the things about
learning something new like how to make
money online is that it acts like a
beacon for where you're freaking going
yeah
it's not going to be
the power boat that gets you there right
now I know you know what I mean because
you need to find another freaking life
jacket which yeah you get a job I know
you need to like just keep going on
these interviews and there's no need
like if you've gone on all these
interviews and people are like you're
amazing and then you don't get it you
think it's because you're too old or
you're too desperately so you're
concerned there's no shame in writing
back and saying I'm not sure if you
filled the position
but I didn't mention that I actually
need a job right my pride got in the way
and so if you haven't filled that
position or maybe you uh are looking for
more peer people I want to make sure you
know I'm not looking to be a consultant
I've never wanted to find a great job
more than ever Than This Moment there's
no shame in that what's the worst
they're going to say yeah we filled the
job well number seven dream big I
guarantee you that right now you are not
even allowing yourself to fully dream or
think about or set goals that are truly
aligned with what you deeply want in
your heart that you aren't even able to
manifest properly because you're not
even honest with yourself about what you
actually want this is a really common
thing because you're allowing yourself
doubt you are allowing your fears your
anxiety your insecurity you're allowing
where you are to dictate and limit where
you want to go and so step one super
important you must allow yourself
give yourself permission to start
dreaming with the lid off now the
scientific reason why this is so
important is because you have a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activity system I write about the RAS
for short the reticular activity system
extensively in the high five habit the
RAS is a filter in your mind and you can
do simple things that change the
structure of that filter in fact the
filter in your mind the res is always
changing so one thing that you can do in
order to teach yourself how to dream
with the lid off is to adopt a simple
habit every single morning I do a very
simple thing I write down five things
that I want that's it when I start my
day after I get up when the alarm rings
I make my bed I pull on my exercise
clothes I set an intention I high five
myself in the mirror I then go out into
the kitchen I crack open my high five
journal and then inside the journal
there are prompts that walk me through
the steps of visualizing and the first
prompt is dream with the lid off set
your spirit free write down five things
every morning that you want and this is
important because when you get what you
want out of your head and you physically
put them on a piece of paper research
shows that you're 42 percent more likely
to achieve those goals simply by writing
them down that's pretty cool secondly
your mind is paying attention and when
you take deliberate action and you write
down what you want you are signaling to
your brain that you deserve to have
these things you're signaling to your
brain that you do want those things
you're not just going to think about
them these are things that matter to you
and that helps train your mind to allow
you to let the desires flow through you
because right now you're not manifesting
properly because you're not even
allowing yourself to dream with the lid
off well number eight get rid of
limiting beliefs what is your limiting
belief what is the thing that you think
about yourself maybe your parents or
your mother or your father taught you to
think that way about yourself maybe you
went through horrible breakup and that
person made you feel unworthy maybe
you've had a bunch of uh setbacks in
your life and that's what gave you that
limiting belief but what is your
limiting belief because today what we're
going to do today is we're going to take
it a step further now that you've
identified your limiting belief we're
going to look at what is it costing you
to choose to repeat it because remember
the quote I started with you can you
have a choice right now you get to
repeat the things you've always done or
you can evolve them and become more
deliberate let's talk about the cost of
that limiting belief
I'm going to go first
so write down your limiting belief I see
a lot of I'm not good enough my mental
health is holding me back I can't run a
successful business I'm lazy and I can't
do anything I'm not healthy enough money
is the issue I'm scared to fail what is
the limiting belief that you have I I'm
certain it has something to do with not
being enough once you've written that
down you're afraid of failure you're not
you don't deserve success all that kind
of stuff I don't know how to start these
are excellent you're doing an excellent
job the first step to moving from that
default into getting deliberate is
actually seeing it so seeing it is
fantastic because now we can start to
understand that whoa this got programmed
in it's my default mode I want to get
rid of it how do we get rid of it well
let's first identify why you want to
let's take a hard look at the cost the
cost of having this limiting belief so
in order to figure out the cost of
having the limiting belief what's my
limiting belief that I'm not a good
person
that's my limiting belief
that I am not a good person that you
don't think I'm a good person but I
don't think I'm a good person
um and here's what you're going to do in
order to identify the cost okay you're
going to ask yourself three questions
and they're very simple
what is this limiting belief in my case
that I'm not a good person what does it
cost me in my past to think this way
what is it costing me in this present
moment to think that I'm not a good
person
and here's the kicker
if I don't evolve this if I don't get
deliberate what is it going to cost me
in the future to continue to think that
I'm not a good person
so in the past
thinking that I'm not a good person
it did a bunch of things first of all it
made me very sad
secondly it made me a liar because I
assumed that I wasn't good enough and
I'm not a good person so I got to
pretend to be somebody else
it also made me cheat on people because
I didn't think I deserve love and it
also by believing that I wasn't a good
person it somehow Justified the bad
behavior I mean if I'm a bad person then
I do bad things right
what does it cost me in the present to
believe that I'm not a good person well
it cost me a lot of Joy it cost me
connection and friendships because I'm
constantly questioning whether or not
people actually like me for me
um it makes me second guess myself and
whether or not I deserve the success and
what does it cost me in the future it's
going to cost me everything if I
continue to repeat this pattern
and I continue to allow myself to
default to believing that I'm not a good
person
I will
never be fully happy I will never be
fully present I probably will not be
successful when we launch this new
daytime talk show in the fall
um and so I got a choice to make and I
want to get rid of this because I can
see what allowing myself to believe that
I'm not a good person is costing me this
exercise of of identifying your limiting
belief and then seeing what it's cost
you in your past your present and your
future is so important for you to do
rule number nine is change your patterns
I know that everybody's problem comes
down to one pattern you're repeating
that you can't see and that pattern is
getting triggered by something that
happened in your past that left you with
this emotional Scar and so for me the
thing that I always always always have
to deal with in myself is the fear of
disappointing somebody so if I'm in a
situation where I start to feel that
it's an old trigger and so when you
finally have a word that describes in a
visceral way this thing you hate about
yourself or this thing that triggers you
or or whatever it may be
that's where the power comes because now
you can name the thing that was once
controlling you and so if you can
identify first of all the pattern you
keep repeating that makes you miserable
or doesn't serve you or makes you lose
your power or has you go numb then you
can start to go back and say well where
did I where did I first start doing this
and what was the experience that
triggered it because that's the root of
the problem right there and when you
expose all of that the trigger and the
emotional
button like my I'm afraid of
disappointing people I'm afraid of
disappointing people I'm not worthy I'm
not worthy and I'm pissed off that I
that this is happening to me now you
have the ability to change it forever
and Rule Number 10 the last time before
some very special bonus Clips is
Manifest your dream life not only do I
want you to close your eyes and picture
yourself going back to the dorm room
notice I'm closing my eyes it's because
manifesting is a habit for me and when I
manifest I get in it man I close my eyes
I go into my mind I am literally in my
imagination there and I not only can see
myself doing the work I can feel it you
can feel what it's like to walk into
that dorm you can feel what it's like to
sit down you can feel the heavy backpack
hit the table you can feel yourself
crack open that book you can feel
yourself sitting at that desk in the
desk light and you can also even feel
what it's like can't you as the Sun
starts to set and it gets darker outside
and the light and your desk starts to
get brighter and take things over you
can just put your yourself right there
and the feeling is super important
because again manifesting is Mind Body
Spirit we got to get your nervous system
involved we've got to make you feel like
you're at the scene one of the reasons
why feeling it is so important is
because it magnifies the imagery in your
mind
and when your mind rehearses something
here's what's cool about your brain your
brain doesn't know the difference
between you studying for that test
are you doing the work to
start that business or get healthy or
put yourself back out there or heal your
trauma or save the money to get that
house that you want or whatever it is
that you're visualizing your brain
doesn't know the difference between you
visualizing those things
and you actually doing them in your mind
it's the same so it's almost like a
training run for a marathon you are
building a muscle that helps you win
when you take the actions it's so cool
and so you not only want to feel what
it's like to study for that test put
yourself at the scene you also want to
feel a sense of Pride that you're doing
the work and the pride piece is really
important because the pride piece acts
almost like a booster it amplifies the
memory imprint when you like bring this
WOW there I am I'm doing the work I'm
proud of myself I'm staying in I'm
putting in the extra work somebody said
no and I kept on going I didn't stop
when the first Venture Capital firm said
they wouldn't invest there I am
investing again when you feel this sense
of pride in yourself it supersizes the
imprint and the rehearsing and so it's a
super important part of the feeling not
only feel the steps feel the pride that
you're doing it this is so important
that I want to give you yet another
example let's say that your bucket list
something on your bucket list is to run
a marathon for me it was on my bucket
list when I was a young mom to run the
New York City marathon now what's
interesting is I applied I got a number
and when I won this number out of a
lottery system with the New York City
marathon I was a brand new mom I was
totally out of shape I was not at all in
any kind of of a place to run the New
York City marathon now here's the thing
I used visualization to help me
lower my fear and my excuses because
when I got the number I did not have a
lot of time if I had been a person who
was not visualizing I probably would
have said uh I don't have enough time to
train I'm not ready I can't do this all
the excuses would have come in but
instead I used visualization now how do
you use visualization for say a marathon
you do not want to visualize crossing
the finish line that is how you
visualize incorrectly
luckily I knew how to visualize at this
moment in my life you need to visualize
yourself going from zero
to preparing to run that race so what
does that mean that means you need to
visualize oh there I am it's five
o'clock in the morning
oh I don't feel like getting up but I'm
getting up and I'm putting on my
sneakers and it's dark out and I don't
feel like going for a run but there I am
going out the door alone in the cold wow
I am going for I'm I'm pretty proud of
myself because I'm training oh here's
another thing you could visualize I'm on
a training run it's Mile seven and it
starts to rain
and I keep going
wow I'm wet and I'm still running I'm
proud of myself because I'm out there
training it's mile 11 and my earbuds
just lost battery
I don't have any more music
I got five more miles to go I'm out here
for almost another hour and I continue
going and I continue going and I see
myself completing that 16 mile training
run and I allow myself to not only feel
what it feels like to push through that
moment when those earbuds run out of
battery
but I also feel proud of myself for
pushing through that's how you prepare
yourself
for the thing that you need to do
because it removes the obstacles that
would stop you from pushing through
number one the secret to an optimistic
mindset you got to be maniacal about
your intake
negativity in here means negativity in
your body gets stored here and
negativity comes out here it becomes
this Loop of negativity and so in order
to build a positive mindset I want you
to be maniacal about positive input that
means really watch your news intake do
not be watching it every day get the
facts
get what you need to know from a trusted
measured
calm factual source and then turn that
off okay that's number one number
two edit your social media
anything on your social media feeds
should be helping you be more resilient
more optimistic
more
um positive
anything
that you're following that triggers you
that is negative that rubs you the wrong
way you know one of the things that I've
noticed
I have some favorite celebrities that I
have um followed for a while because I
think they're funny or I love
um
just kind of their sense of humor but
there are so many people that I have
muted right now because I think that
what they're doing online is so freaking
out of whack seeing people give us
advice about quarantining from the back
of their Estates and mansions telling us
to donate when they're not saying
they're donating seeing this kind of
tone-deaf uh celebrity thing going on
I'm normally not a negative person about
that but I have muted muted muted so
many accounts because it's not doing
anything for me and you got to be
selfish right now you have got to edit
your social media feeds so that your
social media feeds are helping you build
an optimistic and positive mindset and
so every day the second I see some at
mute mute mute mute unfollow unfollow
unfollow because negativity in means
negativity gets stored here means
negativity goes out there from you you
want to put positivity optimism tools
strategies things that keep you laughing
keep things that keep you giving you
things that you can use right now the
second you start getting overloaded with
Corona stuff mute that stuff edit edit
edit your social media based on what you
need that's number one maniacal about
your intake the reason why those
positive I love myself I'm happy with
who I am I accept myself the reason why
those mantras don't work in the
beginning
is because your brain rejects it you've
spent a lifetime trashing your body
trashing yourself telling yourself
you're stupid telling yourself that
you're not good enough telling yourself
that nothing's ever going to work out
for you there is no way that you're
going to be able to stand in front of a
mirror everybody look yourself in the
eye and say today's the day that I'm
going to forget all that stuff and I'm
just going to accept myself and the
reason why it's not going to work is
because all day long you then continue
to beat yourself up
and so what does work well I'm going to
read from chapter 7 of my New York Times
best-selling book the high five habit
the place where we left off for those of
you is Page 91 where we were talking
about training your mind
to change the way that it views the
world intentionally training your mind
to help you and this is an important
thing to learn how to do because if your
mind is going to accept new ways of
thinking and new beliefs about you you
must also train your mind to start to
see the world differently and so you can
do the exercises that I'm teaching you
in conjunction with what I'm about to
teach you about mantras so mistake
number one when it comes to you trying
to become a more positive person and
when you are trying to change the way
that you talk to yourself is you pick a
mantra that you do not at your core
belief okay
you pick something that is the
antithesis of how you actually believe
it yourself and so the mistake number
one that you're making when it comes to
mantras is that you're picking a mantra
that is so far away from where you are
that your mind immediately rejects it so
that's mistake number one
mistake number two
is that you pick a mantra that is simply
just you repeating a statement
that is the exact opposite of how you
speak to yourself and how you treat
yourself all day long and so you know
let me just talk about this on a common
sense standpoint
let's say that you really want to become
healthier okay how many of you want to
become healthier right and you know all
the things you need to do how many of
you want to become healthier and you
know the specific actions you need to
take in order to become healthier
right of of course you know what to do
you know that you could eat better food
you know that you could get more sleep
you know that you could move your body a
little bit more you know that you could
drink more water you know that you could
lay off the booze and the fatty starchy
Foods all those little actions would add
up to a much healthier you are you with
me
yes of course you're with me okay so
knowing what to do is the easy part
knowing kind of what you want that's the
easy part the problem
with sticking to those changes
is that your own negative self-talk
trashes you all day long
and the negative self-talk
I'm so fat oh there I go again I said I
wouldn't have dessert but I did oh I
said I wouldn't drink tonight and I just
did oh I said I was gonna go gluten-free
and I didn't oh I'm sad so I'm gonna do
this oh I don't feel like going for a
walk all of that negative thinking and
talking
it makes you feel less motivated
and less worthy of the change that you
want
and so if you wake up every day and you
have a dream and a goal of becoming
healthier and you know that today you're
going to move your body and today you're
going to drink more water and today
you're going to cut out the gluten and
today you're going to uh do whatever
you're gonna you're gonna uh
donate the clothes that don't fit so you
stop trashing yourself all things that
make you feel better right
if you stand in front of the mirror and
you say
I love you and I accept you exactly how
you are I love you and you deserve to be
you know like and and and I I love
myself and I I'm I I'm gonna be healthy
I'm going to be the best me I can be
and then the next thing you do is you go
into the kitchen
pour a ton of cream into your coffee
your mind is immediately gonna go why
did you just do that oh my God here I go
I'm one minute into this
and your own negative self-talk just
overrode what you said in the mirror
that Mantra that I love myself and I
accept myself by the time you got into
the kitchen you have already trashed
yourself
the pouring the cream in the coffee is
an example that you don't love yourself
you're not sticking to your word and now
your motivation goes boom to change
right
this is why most mantras are complete
you're picking something you
don't believe
so what will work
because the truth is
research says
something if
having an optimistic attitude being kind
to yourself is the secret to motivation
and inspiration
when you treat yourself with respect
when you cheer yourself forward when you
forgive yourself when you screw up you
are going to feel more worthy and you're
going to feel more encouraged and you're
going to feel more likely
to pick yourself back up dump the coffee
with the cream out make the coffee with
the plant-based thing that you said you
would drink shrug your shoulders laugh
at you just instinctively pour the cream
in and then
there you go take a sip of your coffee
so we know that positive talk helps we
know that kindness helps when it comes
to motivation
the problem is you're picking a mantra
that is so Pie in the Sky
and it's making you feel far away from
what you want
and so what will work I'll tell you what
works and then I'm going to read to you
from the high five habit
mantras only work
number one if you believe them
I'm going to say that again mantras only
work
if you believe them
so if you're somebody that has struggled
with self-acceptance
for a very long time
it will not work for you to stand in
front of the mirror when you feel broken
and you're at the beginning of your
journey of taking control of your life
it will not work for you to stand in
front of the mirror and to say I love
and accept myself
because as you stand in front of the
mirror and say that your brain is going
to be like no you dog did you see how
you treated yourself yesterday you do
not love ends up shrunk yourself I know
I'm a ventriloquist now I'm your brain
and then that truth
that your actions don't align with what
you're saying
plummets your motivation and your desire
to change
so what you have to do is pick a mantra
that you actually believe we all know
that we need to love ourselves right
how do you do that
um
I don't know
what is the action that you take yeah we
all know we're supposed to accept
ourselves
we all know we're supposed to uh have
self-esteem and self-worth and
self-validation and self-confidence
how do you build it
and you know the other thing is that we
also are looking outside ourselves for
confirmation validation affirmation of
those things
and so how do you relocate the source of
your self-confidence self-esteem
self-worth self-validation within
yourself so that you're in control of it
big idea right
so uh let me tell you the story about
how I discovered this because it was not
like a oh how do I have another high
five moment you know
I get fired from my talk show
and I uh am essentially fired from my
dream job I then start having speech
after speech after speech after speech
cancel then Houghton Mifflin cancels my
contract for my next book and asks for
me to return money that I've long spent
and why'd they cancel it because because
of pandemic they laid off there are two
reasons first of all they were they were
laying off 45 of the staff but more
importantly let me take responsibility I
was a year late on delivering a man okay
let's be honest I up yet again
yeah I ghosted my publisher and they
fired my ass
um as they should a Long play to ghost
your publisher right how about spend
your money and then ghost you
um but
I found myself again in this like
familiar Place having sort of Echoes
back to a decade ago of oh my God
are we in financial free fall again like
is this ride over kids come home you did
like a hundred speeches in a year prior
to that yeah or prior to the show yep
and then took a pay cut to do this show
yep and look I I've been saving money
I've been very smart about about money
now that I've made it we've paid back
all of our debts something we're both
really really proud of
um and at the same time when it's a fan
in your life your old things will get
triggered and what got triggered for me
is I'm about to lose it all again right
meanwhile just like everybody else on
the planet your kids come home and it's
both a blessing and a horror show to
have your children in a state of
distress as the world is in distress and
I just started to feel overwhelmed and
there was this one morning
where um
I walked into the bathroom
and I was standing in my underwear
brushing my teeth in front of the mirror
and I looked up at the mirror and my
first thought was ugh
I noticed that my jowls were starting to
look like saddle bags on a pack horse at
the Grand Canyon
and uh I had like these crazy Lines by
my eyes and my neck was really like kind
of saggy and one boob was hanging lower
than the other and my gray hair was
coming in and I and as soon as I started
kind of critiquing my thoughts or my my
looks and appearance then my mind Rich
started going I didn't get that email
back to that person and I got that
presentation I need to do and my God
that speech just cancel again what the
am I gonna then I look down and the
dog needs to be walked and then I think
I got a zoom call in nine minutes like I
gotta get my together and before I
knew it my whole mood was low I felt
overwhelmed I had taken myself down
mentally I just wanted somebody to walk
in and be like Mal you it's gonna be
okay like you got this girl like it's
lift your head up you can handle this I
don't know what came over me Rich
this is pathetic
but standing there in my underwear in
front of my bathroom sink
I raised my hand
and high five my reflection
and I cracked a smile because it's so
corny
I even thought of that guy Stuart Smiley
from the SNL skip so remember that I'm
nice I'm kind people like me
when I'm with my day
that was it
snapped a photo though no not that one
oh not that one not the first time and
then I kept doing it I did it probably
for a week or two
and here's the weird thing about it I
started when I woke up after doing this
High five-year-old reflection in the
mirror thing
I actually started to feel like I was
looking forward to it and here's why you
know I've spent a lifetime just like you
standing in front of the mirror and what
I realize now is that when I'm standing
in front of a mirror I'm either
critiquing or picking myself apart
or I'm ignoring myself
and when you start to high-five your own
reflection it starts to build a
partnership within you with yourself
when you walk into the bathroom and you
see your reflection and you've been
greeting it it's like seeing another
person it's the strangest thing you
start to realize how often you ignore or
destroy yourself when you see yourself
or beat yourself up
and here's what's also crazy
you have a lifetime and this is where
the science gets wacky and I'm going to
hit you with so much science because
this stuff is so cool
you have a lifetime positive association
with high-fiving other people sure as a
runner as a racer you have gotten so
many high fives Rich what does a high
five say to you when somebody gives you
one
you feel seen you feel appreciated you
feel energized by it and it's a it's an
exchange of energy it's not the same and
you talk about this in the book it's not
the same as like self-talk because
there's a participation involved in it
there's like a communion yes back to it
yeah and you know if you think about it
you're so good at celebrating seeing and
cheering for other people in your life
you plan birthday parties you reach out
to people when you're worried about them
you help out colleagues you cheer for
your favorite sports teams you high five
people like rich as they're running
races past you you buy people's
merchandise you do all kinds of stuff
for other people
but nobody's taught you how to do it for
yourself in fact the reason why it feels
weird to high-five your own reflection
is because you've been taught to do the
opposite if you know the moment that you
started to think wow I gotta change
myself to fit in I can't be gay I can't
have kinky hair I don't like the color
of my skin because I feel like there's
something wrong with me Society gave you
that message your parents did
um maybe a bully said something to you I
see somebody writing the way that I walk
I see somebody talking about the texture
of their hair I see somebody saying I
always felt like there was something
wrong with me well let me tell you
something everybody I never fit in with
any particular groups of friends let me
tell you something every one of you is
now going I remember that feeling
because I was the only immigrant in my
class I was the only Muslim in my class
I didn't look like the other people I
didn't feel like the other people my
father was so critical right
when you start to get this message from
society or other people or just this
perception that you have that
something's wrong with you this is where
your obsession with changing yourself to
fit in begins this is where your
obsession with people pleasing this is
where this sense that you don't belong
anywhere that you go began and it can
become a habit and so we're going to
unpack this because what I want you to
understand is that you literally
you literally came into this world
perfect whole and complete you are wired
to love yourself you're wired for love
that's why you miss it you're wired for
self-acceptance and the world taught you
that there's something about you that
needs to be changed in order to be liked
or loved and it's simply not true
when you can come back home to yourself
and you can accept and love yourself
first exactly where you are exactly
where you're not
then you'll know the secret to going out
in the world and not feeling like you
never really belong anywhere or you
constantly need to tweak yourself or how
you show up in order to be accepted by
people when you accept yourself as you
are when you love yourself as you are
other people liking or loving you is
just a bonus but it doesn't change how
you feel about yourself I find that even
when change is exciting
it's still scary
even when you know that this big move
that you want to make this big goal that
you want to achieve is something that
you're meant to do
even though you know it it feels
overwhelming
we found an incredible apartment in
Boston and
um are negotiating right now a place and
I had nightmares last night about this
apartment nightmares why well because
anything new any change that you want to
make is going to require you to
literally
end things in your old life you see I
think that so many of us we are really
there are two lives that we have there's
the life that you're currently living
and then there's the one
that you're going to live next hello
whoever's flying that jet I'm going to
say that again we all have two lives
the life you're currently living
and the life
you're going to launch next
and when you're in the middle of
thinking about changes and making big
changes in your life I feel like it's
almost like you're walking across the
suspension bridge as you're building it
and so I have become so indecisive about
everything like I noticed last night I
was trying to reach out to somebody that
was recommended to me as a potential uh
person to hire as an executive producer
for this big podcast for launching this
fall in Boston
and I couldn't even get myself focused
to write the email
now the reason why is because when
you're on edge when you're overwhelmed
when you feel stressed or scared about
something your nervous system kicks into
a state of alert and that impacts your
brain's ability to focus so what do you
need when you feel that way I'll tell
you what you need you need to hit the
freaking reset button you need to get
your mindset back in check you gotta
focus on the simple things that you can
do every day to make yourself feel
steady and secure and clear even as
everything is changing around you you
want to focus on what's in your control
okay
that's what you want to do if you're
going through a divorce you're waiting
for lawyers and this process of
anticipation this process of having to
be patient the first thing that you need
to do is ask yourself and this is by the
way stuff that I talk about in the high
five habit book this is about how to
cultivate a high five attitude when
things are out of your control how to
cultivate a high five attitude when you
are waiting and uh are feeling this
anticipation how to cultivate a high
five attitude when you might be
disappointed I mean you're not going to
have everything be a win in life and so
rule number one
you want to put a hundred and fifty
percent
effort in on something that you care
about okay so if you are sitting here
and you're waiting to hear back on
something or you're waiting to do
something you want to ask yourself if I
put a hundred and fifty percent in one
of the reasons why I just fired off
literally a three-page detailed email to
this landlord basically saying these
girls need a win they all have uh jobs
after working uh internships uh their
senior year they are respectful they're
not looking at your house like a frat
house like so many other people will
they need individual rooms in case they
have to work remote like I went boom
boom boom boom boom they're looking for
a home why did I do that because I think
it's really important when you are
trying to uh make something happen in
your life
really important when you're going for
something that you can personally say to
yourself I have done a hundred and fifty
percent I have gone all in okay and so I
feel like yeah we went all in we got our
application in we got the check
submitted we got the uh Love Letter
submitted and now what I do when I'm
waiting
is I literally say I've put in a hundred
and fifty percent I can give myself that
high five I can look the woman in the
mirror and I can say I know I did
everything that I could what will eat
you alive everybody
is if you're waiting and you know that
you didn't put 150 percent in
it will eat you alive to be
waiting to hear back on a job or on
um you know some test results or on an
application to a program or a school and
to know that you didn't put in a hundred
and fifty percent that's what's going to
cause the disappointment one of the
things that I have to do is I have to
stop holding on to misery I've got to
stop holding on to my own habit of
hesitating and overthinking and feeling
scared and ripping and I'm working on it
um
so I want to know what are you getting
out of this
and I see oh I love this I see so many
of you going oh my God happiness is so
unfamiliar happiness is so unfamiliar
trauma that you haven't released I
relate to this holy cow I'm so glad that
you do
I remember
um a couple months ago I was doing a
bunch of research for a project that
we're doing for audible about happiness
was one of the episodes that we were
working on
and it was kind of striking to me that
the research around happiness shows that
folks that feel happier and are present
to more joy in their life have a habit
that those of us that sort of grip
tightly and feel a little wound up and
stressed and have a hard time relaxing
don't have and that habit that happy
people have is that they make time to do
things
that make them feel happy
and when I started digging into that
research it was a little confronting
because I thought holy
I don't even allow myself I'm so gripped
to feeling stressed out and intense and
bracing for what's next that I haven't
even made it a priority to allow myself
and so becoming a happier person again
I'm going to go back to what I said
earlier in this broadcast the first step
is literally letting go stop gripping
let go of what's no longer serving you
because holding on to it hurts a hell of
a lot more than letting go of it
and so wherever in your life you are not
happy or you are just bracing or
stressed or if stuff isn't working I
guarantee you you're gripping onto
something a relationship a job a habit a
routine a place that you live a mindset
you're gripping on to something that no
longer serves you
and gripping to it is going to cause you
so much more pain and misery than
letting go
it's really that simple
every single ending in your life has a
brand new beginning contained into it
that's it every single ending
that you are avoiding in your life
inside that ending there is a new
beginning I am right in the thick of
this which is why I'm talking about it
the reason why visualization and
picturing yourself succeeding and
allowing yourself to feel the happiness
and the pride that comes with picturing
a positive future the reason why that's
as important is let's say Shelley does
that every single day this week every
day she wakes up she walks for five
minutes and as she's walking on that
treadmill she's visualizing herself
finishing a 10K in six months and how
proud she is every time she does that
she is changing what's going on up here
this isn't something I made up this is
true
and it's not only true based on science
but let's think about this from a common
sense perspective if Shelley wakes up or
if you wake up every single morning and
instead of thinking about the worst case
instead of looking at your body in the
mirror and going I'm so fat I'm so out
of shape I'll never run a 10K it's never
going to happen why didn't I exercise
last year I hate my flabby stomach I
hate my my big thighs I hate how out of
shape I'm embarrassed like if that's
what you're thinking
then that is what you're allowing your
brain to continue to filter the world
through
if you start teaching yourself the skill
of visualizing a positive outcome and
feeling the pride that comes with
achieving that positive goal what
happens for you right now is you start
to think like the kind of person that
does a 10K
if after an entire week what Shelley
does is she looks in the mirror and she
goes I'm getting stronger every day I'm
really proud of myself even though I'm
I'm feeling flabby I'm not saying you're
flabby Shelly but even though I'm
feeling flabby I'm doing the work I can
do this what happens a week from now is
when she sees a registration for a 10K
the old mind that wasn't programmed
correctly would go oh you're fat you're
out of shape you're not prepared for
that don't sign up
but the new mind
because she's been visualizing every
single day the new mind just seven to
ten days later is going to go oh wait a
minute I'm gonna say I'm proud I'm doing
this why don't you sign up
it's gonna filter the world in a very
different way because you're training it
to this is the heart of doing a mindset
reset and this is why visualization
works and why it's an important step and
why I'm so glad you're doing it who can
relate to this
you feel like you're not worthy of the
things that you're accomplishing or that
somehow this is luck or somebody's like
giving you a break but you didn't earn
it God every one of you that blows
really
so what you're dealing with when you
have imposter syndrome is you're dealing
with a lack of self-worth
you literally
kind of see all the things working out
but you've got this like annoying voice
in your head that's saying you don't
deserve this this is luck how many of
you have that story this is locked this
is going to run out this isn't due to me
yeah we got to literally destroy that
voice that is from your past
and part of the reason why you have that
boy that voice by the way is because of
racism it's because of discrimination
it's because of childhood trauma it's
because of uh various experiences that
you've had where either your experiences
growing up or Society at large has made
you feel either overtly or in a really
like gross and sort of Sly way like you
don't belong and so it is critical for
you to start to punch that voice
literally out of your head and I'm going
to give you some steps to do it okay
um the second thing that's really
important is that in addition to
stopping down that voice because it's
not your voice
that is somebody else's voice that your
brain listened to
and then started repeating
and the thing about your brain is that
your brain is this really cool computer
that learns patterns
and what I want you to understand is
that patterns repeat
unless you break and replace them
and if you have a pattern of thinking
like what Heidi has
that says you're not worthy you don't
deserve this luck is going to run out at
some point that you know what's going to
hit the fan again
brace
don't count on anything
like you didn't earn this if you got
that pattern running in your head that
is a broken pattern
you're not broken
that pattern of thinking is broken
and so the Line in the Sand that I want
to draw starting today is you're not
allowed to listen to that garbage
anymore
we are going to go on a mission together
to notice whenever it comes up oh
interesting there it is there's that
pattern it's spinning just like a load
of laundry right up there and I'm going
to teach you once you recognize that
pattern you're going to use this thing
that I created called the five second
rule you're going to count backwards
five four three two one because that
shuts that down
and counting backwards let's all do it
together here we go five four three two
one now notice when you counted did you
feel a little pressure right here
yeah that was me hypnotizing you no I'm
just kidding
um
what you were feeling
is by counting backwards it's a little
brain hack
that interrupts all the garbage that's
here in the interior part of your brain
this is where imposter syndrome lives
everybody this is where anxiety is this
is where self-doubt is this is where
self-criticism is this is where it's all
stored when you notice oh there's that
voice again and you count backwards
54321 you shut it down
and then you awaken this part of your
brain this is the part of the brain that
you used when you were taking the SATs
this is the part of the brain that you
used when you applied for that job when
you speak up in that meeting when you
tell somebody no you cannot borrow my
dress tonight no when you have
boundaries right this is the part of the
brain that gives you immediate control
over what you think and do next
and so that's a really important thing
if you Google word wheel or wheel of
emotions you will find that
um if you ask somebody name as many
emotions as you can most people can name
three happy sad angry
there's literally like 113 of them um
from disgusted to hopeless to and if you
if you start with a core this thing
allows you to start with a core emotion
and go out
because back to the flower example I was
expressing anger
that's not what I was feeling
um I was feeling invisible and forgotten
and so the word wheel is something that
we used several times a week to help
people go from the thing that they are
expressing to communicating what you're
feeling which is a lot like the work
that you wrote about in your book yeah
around wearing masks yeah getting to the
root of the core emotion you're feeling
but not expressing what are the key
principles of how someone deals with
themselves when they love themselves
when they care for themselves what are
those key tenets those those key values
that we can draw ourselves to and
measure against and say am I doing that
for myself I think at the heart of it
are two foundational habits that you
need and one you already mentioned it's
being kind to yourself um
it's really that simple and I know you
know the study that they did in the UK
where they looked at every possible
Behavior change that you could do in
life and whether it was changing in diet
meditation exercise relationship changes
all of it the one change that has the
biggest impact on fulfillment and
happiness is being kind to yourself and
it's the one change we practice the
least because I don't think we know how
yeah I don't how do yeah how do we be
condos well Number One Stop the Beat
Down in the mirror and despite the fact
that it might feel weird or you're going
to resist it or you got a lot of dust oh
boy we gotta wipe it away oh it's more
like mud fly like God Jay has to us the
rest of us are caked with Mod gotta get
some rumble grease in there uh the high
five habit every day is wiping that away
okay that's number one number two
when you catch yourself
in the what if Loop
or the beat down use the five second
rule count backwards five four three two
one interrupt it and start just
interrupting it
because you don't have to listen to it
you can't always control when it pops up
but you can start to create distance
from it meditation obviously helps with
that but in terms of the hand to fist
combat with your own brain I prefer
punch back 54321 and then I literally go
I'm not thinking about that another
strategy that you can use as you're
doing the hand-to-hand combat with your
own brain is come up with like an avatar
for this negative voice okay and make it
really good like when our son was really
profoundly struggling with anxiety he's
16 now he started to call that worry
wart in his head that was beating him up
Oliver and he looked like this big
pimply bully of a kid that was out of
the Diary of the Wimpy Kid and he would
literally say when he was nine years old
shut up Oliver Mike you're not invited
to sleep like he would literally talk to
it and it sounds like you're giving your
kid multiple personalities that's not
actually what's happening you're
leveraging objectivity so you separate
yourself from the voice that's talking
to you yes
um another thing that you can do I love
this for worrying oh this is a genius to
steal your word uh move when you catch
yourself doing the what ifs because we
know there's two forms of worrying right
there's the type of worrying that just
destroys you that's destructive worrying
where you just ruminate what if what if
what if then there's the positive form
of worrying which is productive because
it it motivates you to change when you
get stuck in the what if what if what if
interrupt it with us five four three two
one and then go what if it all works out
what if this turns out to be one of the
hardest things I do but the best
decision I've ever made um
what if placing a bet on myself
was the moment my life changed
what if it all works out
because you can't argue with that and it
literally stops that sort of cycling
because worrying is just a habit that
you have it's like a pathway that you've
plowed in your mind and it's a
protection mechanism you're actually not
a procrastinator you're not a worrier
you're just afraid yeah and by staying
in your mind you think you're safe
and really what you're doing is you're
holding yourself back from living the
life that you're meant to live I love
that that's such a great answer so
that's because I've got a couple of yeah
let's be kind to yourself and then
there's another one and then the other
ones yeah keep the little promises that
you make to yourself
and there's two simple ways you can
practice this that everybody's Gonna
Hate
when you set the alarm the night before
I don't believe in having the same
wake-up time every morning
because I think if you have a normal
life
things are constantly changing and so I
think if you were to have one simple
habit which is the night before you go
to bed think about when you need to wake
up to truly support yourself and then
intentionally set your alarm and if you
want to get really intentional with the
science here make it like a random odd
number don't make it six o'clock make it
6 17 because there's a purpose behind
that and then when that alarm rings
don't think about it like an obligation
I want you to think about it like it's a
promise that you're going to practice
keeping
and this is where you can use the five
second rule you're just going to count
backwards five four three two one to
interrupt all of the desire in your mind
and body to stay in bed or to hit the
snooze button or to argue against what
you need to do and you're going to push
through that resistance and take action
and by getting out of bed simply when
you said you would you are again
behavioral activation therapy you're
acting like a person who keeps their
promises you talk a lot about taking
responsibility for that recognizing
nobody's coming to save you something
you said in the book it's something that
you've said in interviews something that
I absolutely think is really powerful
how do we use that why is that important
to recognize
important to recognize because first of
all nobody is coming
[Laughter]
for somebody to just screw you to pick
you to save you to rescue to give you
your shot it's not happening
like at some point you got to wake up
and realize when you're 18 and you're
out of that house you have to parent
yourself
your life is your responsibility and as
a woman one of the things that I found
to be extraordinarily transformational
is when I stopped in a very traditional
sense looking to my partner to be
responsible for providing for me
providing financially providing the
support providing when I realized wait a
minute it starts with me
I have to be
able to figure out how to make myself
happy that's by the way the secret to a
happy relationship marry somebody who's
happy and work on your own happiness
preach and so when you stop Outsourcing
your happiness your validation your
support all of it and you bring it back
in and you get responsible for it it
sounds scary it's so liberating because
you could do anything
when you're responsible when you're the
driver of your life when you're not
looking out to anybody else to fix it
for you can you ask for help of course
but the buck stops with you you're the
one that has to do the work you're the
one who has to push your own ass you're
the one who has to figure out what makes
you happy you're the one who has to
figure out and become self-aware about
what you need and then you're the one
that has to
find whatever it is the courage or being
humble enough to ask for help even if
it's asking for help from the biggest
Ally that you have which is the person
staring back at you in the mirror every
damn morning
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
recent interview with Mel Robbins one on
one check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I hope
your business goes bankrupt Evan Evan
you're a terrible person I spent the
first
40-some years of my life trying to be
somebody else I'll give you guys a
secret way